We're on problem 33 and it
asks, which equation
represents a line that is
parallel to y is equal to
minus 5/4 x plus 2?
So a line that's parallel will
have the same slope.
And we can just look at this, we
could inspect this and say,
OK, the slope of this line is
the coefficient on the x term.
So slope on this line
is right there.
Because the slope is
equal to minus 5/4.
And so we just have to look at
the other choices and say,
which one has the same
slope of minus 5/4?
And choice A actually is, choice
A is y is equal to
minus 5/4 x plus 1.
So it has the exact same
slope and it's just
shifted down by 1.
So A is our choice.
Now problem 34.
Let me copy and paste
this one.
Let's see, I can paste it.
All right, and they ask us,
which graph represents the
solution to this system
of inequalities?
OK, so we could take each of
these inequalities and then,
what we want to do is we want
the area that satisfies both
of these inequalities.
So let's take a look
at the first one.
And I like to always have it
in kind of y is equal to mx
plus b form.
So let's do that.
So the first one says 2x
is greater than or
equal to y minus 1.
If we add 1 to both sides, we
get 2x plus 1 is greater than
or equal to y.
And if we just want to write
that in a way that we're used
to seeing it, y-- I'm just
switching it around.
y is less than or equal
to 2x plus 1.
So let's see which one
this represents.
We have a line, 2x plus 1, so
the y-intercept is 1 and the
slope is 2.
So let's see.
So that's this line here.
y-intercept 1 and if
we go over to the
right 2, we go up 4.
However much we increase
in x, we increase twice
as much with y.
That's what the slope
tells us.
And that's this line in
this chart like that.
Fair enough.
So that's that line.
And they're saying y
is less than that.
So we want the area
below that graph.
So it's not this one.
This one they're shading in
the area above that line.
For any x and y that's on the
line, they're shading in y is
greater than that point.
No, but we what y is less
than that point.
For any y on the point,
all the y's less
than it satisfy it.
So based on the information now,
this one seems to be a
pretty good candidate.
I haven't looked at the
other line yet.
And frankly, neither of--
I guess, no neither.
Maybe this one might be a
candidate because this
is also less than.
Maybe we have to be less than
both of these lines, right?
This is the line that
we just figured out.
We're definitely less than it.
Maybe we have to be less than
that second line as well.
So if we have to be greater
than that second line, we
haven't looked at that yet.
It's going to be choice C.
If we have to be less than the
second line and this first
line, then we're going
to be in choice D.
Let's see what the second piece
of information tells us.
OK, well they actually have a
typo and they don't give us
enough information
to actually-- let
me look up the answer.
Because they didn't even write
a greater than or equal or
nothing here.
So I have to see what they
probably intended.
OK, so I just looked up the
answer and they said that the
answer is C.
So they must want us to be
greater than this second line.
So let's figure out what
this should have been.
What should have this-- should
there have been an equals?
Well, definitely not
an equal sign.
But should there have been
a greater than or
less than or whatever?
We'll figure that out.
So let's see.
2x minus 5y circle 10.
We don't know if there's an
equal there or less-- this is
almost a better exercise than
what they intended.
Let's see.
If we were to add 5y to both
sides, I just want to get y on
the other side.
And I don't want to have
to say flip signs and
divide by minus 5.
So let me get 5y on
the other side.
So I'll add 5y to both sides.
So we get 2x.
Whatever inequality sign,
so that could
be an equal or whatever.
10 plus 5y.
Subtract 10 from both sides.
So you get 2x minus
10 circle 5y.
Remember that circle could
be an equal sign.
Well, it's not an equal.
It's either a greater than
or equal or it's a
less than or equal.
And then we can divide both
sides by 5 and you get 2
divided by 5 x minus 2, some
greater than or equal or less
than or equal sign, y.
Now they told us C was the
answer because I had to look
it up because they didn't give
us any inequality sign there.
If C is the answer that means
we're going to-- we want all
y's that are below
the first line.
So below this line right here.
So that's that area.
And if we're in this grey area,
all y's that are above
this bottom line.
So if we're above this bottom
line, this bottom line
is 2/5 x minus 2.
So we want all y's that
are greater than that.
Sorry, I've done it-- we want
all the y's that are greater
than that. y is greater
than this thing.
So that sign in this
problem should have
been a less than sign.
I'm saying y is greater
than this.
But if you read it left to
right, you have 2x minus 2 is
less than y.
And so we figured
out the sign.
And you might be saying,
hey, wait.
How come this area over
here doesn't work?
Well if you think about
it, this area is
above our first line.
This area is y is greater
than 2x plus 1.
It's above our first line.
And it's actually below
our second line.
So it's actually the
opposite area.
Anyway, next problem.
The answer was C.
Next problem, 35.
OK, let's see.
I'll copy and paste this one.
I think the choices
are interesting.
What is the solution to this
system of equations?
All right, so let's see if we
can get in a form that makes
it easy to look at.
Let's take that first
equation and let's
add 3x to both sides.
If you add 3x to both sides,
that first equation becomes
positive 3x plus y is
equal to minus 2.
All I did is I did plus 3--
you can't see that.
I added plus 3x to both sides
of this equation.
And of course, that
cancels with that.
All right, and now let' see.
That second equation is 6x plus
2 is equal to minus 2.
Well let me do something else
to this equation and I think
it'll become apparent
that these are
actually the same line.
So if you take this first
equation and multiply both
sides of it by 2,
what do you get?
Let's see.
Multiply 3x plus y by 2, you
get 2 times 3x is 6x.
Plus 2 times y.
You have to distribute the 2.
Plus 2y is equal to.
Minus 2 times to 2 is minus 4.
And they're the same line.
So when you're solving a system
of equations, you're
figuring out, where do those
two equations intersect?
If they're the same lines, they
intersect everywhere.
So they have an infinite
number of solutions.
So the answer is choice D.
Next problem.
They give us another
one like that.
They want to know the ordered
pair that's a
solution to this equation.
I'll just copy and paste
the equation there.
OK, so the easiest thing to do
is probably to just subtract
the second equation from
the first equation.
And instead, I'll actually
write it out explicitly.
So the first question is x
plus 3y is equal to 7.
Instead of subtracting this one
from that one, let's just
multiply the second question by
negative 1 and then we'll
add the two equations.
So if we multiply this bottom
equation by negative 1 we get
minus x minus 2y is
equal to minus 10.
And the whole reason why I'm
doing that is I know when I
add these two left-hand sides,
the x and the minus x are
going to cancel out.
And then I can just
solve for y.
That's why you immediately see,
they have an x and an x.
If we subtract this from that,
they'll cancel out.
So if we add these two
equations, the x' cancel out.
3y minus 2y is equal to y.
And 7 minus 10 is equal
to minus 3.
Fair enough.
And now we can substitute back
in to figure out an x.
So let's use the
first equation.
x plus 3 times minus 3-- we
figured out what y is-- is
equal to 7.
And then you get x.
3 times-- minus 9
is equal to 7.
x is equal to-- add 9 to both
sides of this equation.
x is equal to 16.
So the solution is 16 comma
minus 3. x and y.
And that is choice D.
All right, problem 37.
Marcy has a total of 100
dimes and quarters.
If the total value of the coins
is $14.05, how many
quarters does she have?
All right, so let's say that d
is a number of dimes and q is
the number of quarters.
So if you take the number of
dimes plus the number of
quarters she has 100 coins.
That's this piece of information
right there.
And then the total value
of the coins.
It's going to be 0.10 times the
number of dimes plus 0.25
times the number of quarters.
And they tell us that that
is equal to $14.05.
And that's this piece
of information.
The total value of the
coins is $14.05.
And they say, well, how many
quarters does she have?
So we just have to
solve for q.
So let's do that.
So if we want to cancel out the
d's, what we could do is
we can multiply this
top equation by
let's say, minus 0.1.
And I'm doing that so
it cancels out with
this d right here.
Let me do it in a
different color.
So if I multiply that top
equation times minus 0.1 I get
minus 0.1d-- I could write
1-0 if I want-- d.
Minus 0.10q is equal to-- what's
minus 1/10 of 100?
Well that's minus 10, right?
100 times 0.1 is 10 and we're
doing a minus 0.1.
All right, now we can add
these two equations.
0.1d minus 0.1d, those
cancel out.
0.25q minus 0.1q, that's equal
to-- let me switch colors.
That's equal to 0.15q
is equal to-- and
what's 14.05 minus 10?
That's equal to $4.05.
Just to get rid of the decimals,
we can multiply both
sides of this equation by 100.
So we'll get 15q is
equal to 405.
So q.
We divide both sides
of this by 15.
And so how many times
does 15 go into 405?
15 goes into 40, what?
Two times.
2 times 15 is 30.
Get a 10.
105.
15 goes into 105 seven
times I think.
7 times 5 is 35.
7 times 1 is 7.
Plus 3 is 10.
27.
So q is equal to 27.
So Marcy has 27 quarters.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.